hello everyone and welcome to the
conclusion of the Tata steel Masters
2024 after 13 Rounds of classical chess
we had a 4way tie we ended up on eight
and a half points gues ended up on eight
and a half points Anish gir on eight and
a half and nbe abatan 8 and a half and
in the semi-finals of the tie breaks of
the Tata still
2024 we eliminated Notre Beck abdat and
gesh eliminated Anish giri it was a
really um the games were really really
tough I'm going to revisit some of them
tomorrow so you guys can have a better
idea of what happened if you haven't
seen them but it was interesting because
anir first defeated gesh and then gesh
had win on Demand with the black pieces
he was able to do so and in the end he
even won the match so this is the finals
Wei versus gukesh I know it's a little
bit sad to you know end a 13 round
classical event with a Blitz game but
you know there has to be a tiebreaker so
uh first game between the two of them
ended in a draw this is the second
second game which means if anyone wins
this one that's it he is the winner of
Tata still 2024 we with the white pieces
opens with Knight to F3 he goes for the
ready opening uh Pawn to D5 we have Pawn
to E3 and Knight to F6 uh we have Pawn
to C4 uh and now Pawn to E6 so
transposing into the ainur defense of
the English opening B3 and now Bishop to
D6 we have Bishop to B2 uh and now there
are uh moves that have been played here
is a fairly playable position but Knight
to C6 is a new move by gesh and it is
now already as of move five that we have
a completely new game and it does look a
little bit weird you know uh a good old
filor would probably slap you on the
face if he saw you blocking your Pawn
like that uh but you know it's 2024
anything can be played so C captures on
D5 uh we have e captures and now Pawn to
G3 where is preparing the F get to the
bishop and Castle King side we have
castles uh Bishop to G2 and now now
Queen to E7 we have castles and now at
Knight to E5 GES wants to trade stuff on
E file and then advances Pawn to C6 and
he will be very very solid so Knight
captures Bishop captures uh and we trade
everything Bishop captures Queen
captures attacks The Rook here Knight to
C3 uh puts pressure on D5 and just Pawn
to C6 and gukesh I believe could not be
happier with his position here he needs
a draw in order to force further tie
breaks and now Wei plays Pawn to B4 uh
the idea of course is he wants to play
Pawn to B5 so okay Pawn to H5 gues
strikes on the king side he wants to
play Pawn to H4 so Pawn to H3 getting
ready for that and now Bishop to F5
continuing development and now Pawn to
B5 now uh it's very interesting gcash
played Bishop to F5 probably with the
idea of going Bishop to D3 and now way
is B5 idea uh really does invite Bishop
to D3 and it's even the top move
recommended by the engine but I guess
gkes just didn't want to over complicate
things um against Wei so he didn't go
for a c captur on B5 uh and then
something like Queen to B3 would put
pressure on D5 B5 and yeah it's a funny
position but after Bishop to C4 black
should be uh you know just better up a
clean Pawn but gukesh did not go for it
he played Pawn to D4 and now e captures
on D4 we have Queen captures on D4 B
captures and C6 B captures and now Queen
to F3 not going for Bishop captures and
C6 would be a bit too dangerous as this
is a 3 plus two game H so Bishop to E6
and now Queen to E3 we offering a queen
trade says okay if you trade I'm just
going to fix my Pawn structure get rid
of my weakness on D2 and you will be
stuck with your weak C6 Pawn so okay
Queen back to D7 gues of course doesn't
want to trade he puts pressure on the H3
Pawn King to H2 and now Pawn to H4 uh
pushing further and here G captures an
H4 you you you might consider also a
move like Pawn to G4 but you you should
consider it very briefly because here
just Bishop captures on G4 and if you
recapture Knight captures with a nice
Royal Fork uh so that's the problem so G
captures sorry G captures an H4 by way
uh Rook F to E8 nicely aligning The Rook
with the queen and queen to G5 as the G
file is now semiopen uh Rook to G1
followed by Rook to G7 is what we wants
to do at some point so Queen to D6 check
Queen to G3 now blocking offering a
queen trade again he wants to fix his
Pawn structure and Rook a to d8 of
course gash wants we to capture but you
know in the meantime he's putting
pressure on that D2 Pawn so Rook a to D1
and now Bishop to C4 attacking The Rook
Rook D1 is impossible because you just
capture and then after Rook captures to
pick up the D2 Pawn so here Rook to
G1 uh the move that gkes wanted to play
as uh well he would very much like to
Checkmate the black king however with
this pin for the moment you can't uh do
that so Knight to H5 attacks the queen
and here we do have a trade Queen
captures Rook captures Bishop to F3
attacks the Knight on H5 and now Knight
back to F6 we have Rook to G5 now uh
with the idea of Rook D to G1 and just
busting through through the H file uh
King to f8 getting rid getting the the
King off of the Gile we have Rook to C5
now attacking the bishop and the bishop
to D5 as you also need to defend your
weak C6 Pawn so Bishop to D5 and now we
trades we have Knight captures Knight
captures and now Pawn to D4 finally The
Rook um gets some squares uh uh you
before D4 it was pretty much stuck on D1
hemed in by its own D2 Pawn Rook to F6
going after the bishop Here and Now Rook
to D3 just defending uh Knight to B4
attacking the rook and Rook to B3 we
have Knight back to D5 and now Pawn to
H5 uh nice ly uh advancing the pawn in
the future H6 might be an idea but also
you are stopping any Rook to G6 idea so
Pawn to G6 this Pawn to G6 move is not
necessary guuk should probably just uh
make a solid move like Rook to d8 or REM
maneuver the Knight with Knight to E7
but he goes for Pawn to G6 and he just
gives way some targets H captures F
captures and King to G3 it's uh very
very difficult to make moves here as
both of them are now very very low on
the clock they're below the 10sec mark
just uh uh maybe not below the 10c mark
maybe here they were below the 30 second
Mark but they're mainly playing on the
increment the two seconds so Knight to
E7 uh we have Bishop to E4 and now Rook
to D6 putting pressure on the D4 pawn
and just Rook to C4 here Wei could even
win the game with a move like Rook to E5
but it's impossible to spot with little
time on the clock uh point is that if
you play Rook captures on D4 there's
Bishop captures on G6 and that's just it
Rook to F3 is coming uh regardless of
you capturing the bishop or not even if
you capture Rook to F3 check will be
deadly the King has to move away from
The Rook Rook captures and now your
position is just winning uh so instead
Rook to C4 he he wants to defend his D4
Pawn of course Rook e to d8 now gkes
piles up on the pawn Rook beat to B4 and
King to F7 we have King to F3 uh King to
F6 and now King to E3 Rook D4 maybe a
little bit more precise but uh seconds
on the clock Rook 8 to D7 and now Rook
to B8 trying to harass the black king
from behind uh Rook to E6 and now King
to D3 just unpinning we have Rook e to
D6 and now Rook to f8 uh with check King
to G7 uh Rook back to B8 and King to F6
guash would very much um like a draw
here but we plays on King to C3 we have
Rook to E6 and again Pawn to F3 now
defending the bishop so the king can
remain here and maybe even go to the
queen to the queen side we have Knight
to D5 with check King to B3 and Knight
back to E7 so just trying to be very
solid here H4 by way uh Knight to F5
going after d H4 Pawn now King back to
C3 as the D4 Pawn was also hanging and
here we have Knight back to D6 uh if you
play Knight captures on H4 then just
Bishop captures on C6 you have to uh
defend the C6 Pawn so instead GES just
goes Knight to D6 attacks The Rook here
now the idea is of course that if Rook
captures on C6 you will play Knight
captures on e4 with check and then pick
up the Rook here but luckily you can
also just take the pawn with the bishop
which is what we does Bishop captures
and C6 Rook to C7 now uh not allowing
the bishop to move otherwise Rook
captures and C4 will win so Rook C5
where the Rook is nicely defended Rook
to E3 with check King to D2 attacking
the rook and now Rook to A3 uh Bishop to
D5 and now Rook to D7 of course you have
to to avoid The Rook trade here The Rook
was attacked and also the A2 Pawn is
defended so Bish Rook captures an A2 is
not an option uh Rook to C6 and now Rook
to A5 gesh is now uh gues is now down
two pawns and he can't really afford to
trade any pieces we have Bishop back to
B3 King to E7 and now Rook to G8 we you
trying to pick up another Pawn so King
to F6 Rook to E8 and now King to F5 but
now he just runs into Bishop to E6 with
check uh and he was in this position on
move 59 that gues resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
really a tough loss for gesh but it is
we who who wins not just this match but
also the Tata still 2024 and it's
incredible Wei who we haven't heard of
him for for quite some time you know we
know he's an incredible player he's a
he's a prodigy he he he always you know
every second game he plays is basically
an immortal game and he played the the
classical tournament um incredibly
impressively uh he even ended the check
out the live ratings after this event so
these are the top 20 after the event has
finished uh so okay Magnus still first
Fabby the two 2800s then we have Hikaru
ding Anish alza Yan pom wo and then Wei
jumps into the world top 10 so he
improves by seven spots he was world
number 16 before entering the tournament
and um yeah I mean absolutely incredible
also won 17 points sauat also won 17
points uh Prague also onon 2747 so
really really strong performances Anish
giri also won 13 points in the event uh
so pretty pretty incredible stuff ding
lost 17 points neppo lost 10 points uh
yeah but other than that yeah we
absolutely incredible stuff and what's
more interesting is that he won a
classical tournament where five
candidates participated a world champion
and a women's world champion and you
know he just comes out on top so uh yeah
it's a definitely a strong event for him
we would definitely appreciate seeing
him in the candidates tournament but you
know one one event will not Grant you a
seat at the candidates tournament uh but
yeah F also um uh Chang their rules
change the rule book on how you can
enter the next candidates tournament so
I'm probably going to talk a little bit
more about that uh in the next video
that I make where I'm going to mostly
showcase wees games from this tournament
yeah incredible stuff hope you enjoyed
this short coverage um like I said
tomorrow I'm probably going to cover two
or three wees games that I've missed
from the event because all of them like
I said all of them you know every game
he plays is an immortal even the one
against Notre where he eliminated him in
in the tie breaks here was absolutely
crushing with the black pieces so
probably going to show that one H but
yeah you know tough tough break for gues
he he did everything right uh he he lost
that half a point to pragnan and then on
that three B repetition you know it
could have been a completely different
tournament he could have uh probably won
Soul first place if that didn't happen
but yeah he still got to the finals he
still faced we uh but you know uh when
You Face we you you you you don't know
what will happen so I hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Lana is the
best wife in the world Samuel K ghard
hlan Hans Anderson and David gasparian
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on everything
that's happening in the Chess World Plus
of course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day